-Not a single Republican voted
for the historic
$1.9 trillion COVID relief bill
passed by the Senate this week.
And in fact, Republicans spent
most of the weekend
trying to derail it while
still whining about Dr. Seuss.
For more on this,
it's time for a closer look.
♪♪
The past few months have offered
a deeply-revealing look
at the state of
American democracy
and the course it could take
over the next few years
without major reforms.
On the one hand,
we saw a political faction
which represents a minority
of American voters
try to overturn
an election they lost
and then sow a violent
insurrection to interfere
with the lawful counting
of electoral votes.
And then about two months later,
we saw 50 Senate Democrats,
who represent about
41 million more Americans
than the 50 Senate Republicans,
vote to deliver one of the
largest rescue bills in history,
which has been massively
popular in poll after poll.
And not a single Republican
joined them
in the Senate or in the House.
They were too busy
doing dumb [bleep] like this.
-"Green Eggs and Ham"
by Dr. Seuss.
"I am Sam.
I am Sam. Sam, I am."
"Do you like green eggs
and ham?"
"I do not like them, Sam, I am."
"You do not like them.
Say -- so you say.
Try them, try them,
and you may."
"Say! I like green eggs and ham.
I do. I like them Sam, I am."
"I do so like green eggs
and ham.
Thank you. Thank you Sam, I am."
Enjoy your day.
-Well I can't now.
Not after that performance.
There's nothing cringier
than watching
a grown adult
in a suit read Dr. Seuss
to an empty room
with no children around.
Is that the Fox News version
of "Reading Rainbow?"
"Reading Rainblows?"
This is what a hostage video
would look like
if Barney was the kidnapper.
Serious Stockholm Syndrome when
you get kidnapped by Barney --
you're so mad
when you get rescued.
You don't understand.
I love him. He loves me.
Most importantly, green eggs and
ham isn't canceled, ya goober!
It's on Amazon's
best seller list,
thanks to all your whining.
I wouldn't be surprised if
we find out
the Seuss people did this
just to move more product.
"No one's buying our books."
[ Dramatically ] "Say we're
pulling them for racism.
They will fly off the shelves!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normally ] No one
canceled anything.
The copyright holder
voluntarily withdrew
six books from publication
because of racist imagery
and language.
The books include titles
like "The Cat's Quizzer"
and "McElligot's Pool,"
which I'm guessing
is where Steve Bannon drowned.
When it comes to Fox News
and the Republican Party,
their brand is overreaction.
Take their feigned outrage
over "The Muppet Show."
Disney decided to add
a disclaimer
in front of an episode
with a Confederate flag,
among others.
But it's Fox News,
not Fox Nuance.
So they act like Kermit the Frog
was thrown in an unmarked van,
never to be seen
or heard from again.
You can still see the episode.
And just to show
you cancel culture isn't real,
it stars Johnny Cash,
who shot a man in Reno
just to watch him die.
No second reason.
Anyway, the point is this
is what our
two major political factions
have decided to spend
their time on --
one's trying to deliver
a massively popular relief bill
that includes direct payments,
expanded child
and unemployment benefits,
and funding for vaccinations.
And another is holding
story time for ghost children
in a library of the damned,
trying to overturn the election,
and trying to prevent people
from voting in the next one.
The tidal wave of anti-voting
legislation unleashed
by Republican state legislatures
over the past few weeks
has gotten so insane
that Georgia Republicans
have proposed a series of bills
that would,
among other things,
target Black voters,
ban no-excuse absentee ballots,
roll back Sunday voting,
and ban what is known
as "line warming,"
the practice of having
volunteers provide water,
snacks, chairs and other
assistance to voters in line.
Holy [bleep]. They're trying to
ban voters from having water,
snacks, and chairs?
Republicans want to turn voting
into one of those
extreme radio station contests
where whoever goes the longest
without peeing
gets two backstage passes
to an Aerosmith concert.
If the GOP had their way,
there would be one polling place
in every state open
for like three hours a week,
and instead of a school,
it would be at
the end of an "American Ninja
Warrior"-style obstacle course.
If you don't bring
three forms of ID,
you get knocked off the platform
by a giant foam hand.
Also, I love
how the party of freedom
wants to make it illegal
to give someone a snack.
They're canceling snacks.
Quick get Kevin McCarthy
on YouTube
so he can read the ingredients
on a pack of Oreos.
[ Imitating Kevin McCarthy]
Unbleached enriched flour,
canola oil or palm oil.
Enjoy your day,
[ Normally ] I guess in
the GOP's America,
voters aren't allowed to
drink water
unless it's from
McElligot's pool.
So that's the central story
of our political culture
at the moment.
One coalition is becoming
increasingly deranged
and extreme
and anti-democracy,
and the other is still committed
to competent governance.
And look, that doesn't mean
this bill is perfect --
far from it. For one thing,
the bill keeps the expanded
unemployment benefits at $300
rather than the original $400
Democrats had aimed for,
and it sets them
to expire by Labor Day --
a deal forced by moderate
Democrat Joe Manchin,
for reasons no one
seems to understand
on either side of the aisle.
When asked
what Manchin's issue was,
his fellow moderate Democrat,
Jon Tester, said,
"I don't know. I really don't."
Republican Shelley Moore Capito
said,
"I have no idea
what he's doing."
Cool, because that's what
you want in a Senate
that's split 50/50 --
a wild card.
So, I know that photo
right there was taken
just as Manchin found out
he was a Democrat.
[ Bewildered ] "I am?
Oh, man, in West Virginia?
Hoohoohoo, good luck to me."
[ Normally ] It's weird to hear
senators talking about
one of their colleagues
the way baseball announcers
talk about a streaker.
"And now he's wrestling
the T-shirt gun away
from the Philly fanatic.
Do you know what he is doing
out there, Buck?"
"I really don't. Either we're
all getting T-shirts
or we're going to see a man get
his nuts tasered off."
A 50/50 split means
all the Democrats have to
stick together.
You can't have one guy
splintering off the last minute.
It's like an escape room where
everyone's focused on the clue
hidden under the genie's lamp,
and one guy's like,
"I bet I can just
kick this door down."
"Devin, can you just
use your brain for once?"
"Uh, and waste these quads?
No, thank you."
Then there's the fact that a
group of Democratic senators
and Independent Angus King
split off and joined Republicans
in voting down a proposal
to raise the minimum wage
to $15 an hour, which is wildly
popular in polls and something
President Biden campaigned on.
One member of that group,
Arizona senator Kyrsten Sinema,
has gotten a lot of criticism
for the enthusiastic thumbs down
she gave the bill on the Senate
floor,
like a judge on
"America's Got Talent"
after an 8-year-old
bombs doing stand up.
"Sorry, Tyler,
but the 90s called --
they want
their joke format back."
But let's not lose sight
of the senators
from safe Democratic seats
like Chris Coons
and Tom Carper in Delaware,
who voted it down for no reason
other than they don't like it
on policy grounds.
I mean, what's wrong
with you guys?
You're not going to face any
serious Republican opposition,
and yet you're still siding
with them?
Watching these guys is like
watching LeBron play defense
against himself.
By the way, playing defense
against himself
is the only way he'll ever
get called for a foul.
I'm just kidding. I love him
and I want him to be my friend.
With all that said,
it's important not to understate
the truly seismic nature
of this bill
and all the incredible good
it will do for millions of poor
and working-class Americans.
For one thing,
it's way bigger than
the 2009 stimulus,
and that's a good thing
because the 2009 stimulus
wasn't nearly enough.
This bill sends about
$350 billion
in state and local governments
to keep services running,
save pensions and schools
and public transit,
and keep people employed.
It sends out direct payments
to about 85% of Americans,
and it expands unemployment
benefits and child benefits.
One study suggested that
the bill will reduce poverty
by a third, lifting nearly
13 million Americans out of it,
and that child poverty would
be reduced by more than half.
Meanwhile, for a family of four
with one working parent
and one who remains unemployed
because
of childcare constraints,
the benefits could total more
than $12,000.
But what about the tax credit
for high earners
who use S-corporations to buy
fine art for their catamarans?
Who will think of
the catamarans?!
Anyway, the point is, this is
a flawed but really good bill
that delivers
desperately-needed help
to the people who need it most,
on a scale that's necessary
to make an actual difference
in the economy
and in people's lives.
And that, of course,
means Republicans did everything
they could to derail it
with [bleep] like
Texas Senator Ted Cruz,
who offered an amendment
to stop the checks
from going to
undocumented immigrants,
even though the bill
doesn't do that anyway,
and he was immediately rebuffed
by Illinois Senator Dick Durbin.
-Mr. President, moments ago,
the Democrats in this chamber
just voted to send $1,400
stimulus checks to murderers,
to rapists, and child molesters
incarcerated in prison.
This amendment before us today
provides that
the stimulus checks
should not go to illegal aliens
in this country.
Should your money --
should taxpayer money be sent?
$1,400 to every illegal alien in
America.
-Mr. President, the statement
of the senator from Texas
is just plain false.
False! Let me be clear.
Undocumented immigrants do not
have Social Security numbers
and they do not qualify for
stimulus relief checks, period.
And for you to stand up there
and say the opposite
is just to rile people up
over something that's not true.
-Will the senator yield
for a question?
-No, I won't.
It is not true. And we know
what's going on here.
They want to be able
to give speeches
and say the checks go
to undocumented people.
-Cruz is so bad at this,
he can't even be subtle
about his [bleep]
fear-mongering.
"Democrats just voted to send
stimulus checks to murderers,
rapists, child molesters,
Chuckys, Jasons, Xenomorphs,
Freddy Kruegers, and Kuatos."
Second, I love his sociopathic
little chuckle at the end there.
Millions out of work,
in poverty,
facing food insecurity,
and it's all so funny to him --
or maybe it was just remembering
when he grabbed the maracas away
from a mariachi
at the Señor Frogs in Cancun.
So Democrats stuck together
to fend off GOP stonewalling
and passed a historic
relief bill
that could not come
at a more precarious time.
We're currently in what may well
be a crossroads in the pandemic.
There's lots of good news,
but also some bad news.
Vaccinations are accelerating at
a previously unthinkable pace,
with nearly 3 million doses
administered on Saturday alone.
Cases have fallen as
dramatically as they ever have
since the peak in January.
But cases also now
seem to be plateauing
at a stubbornly high number
of 60 to 70 thousand per day,
which leaves more
than enough virus circulating
for one more deadly
outbreak before summer,
and yet several states are
racing to prematurely lift
mask mandates
or open up entirely,
from Texas to Mississippi,
Alabama, and even Connecticut,
where the mask mandate
will remain in effect,
but capacity limits
will be lifted on retail,
restaurants, and gyms.
Why would you
lift capacity on gyms?
The whole business model for
gyms is that people join them
and then don't go.
It's just a key fob
that costs $100 a month
to carry around.
There should be capacity
limits on gyms
even when there isn't
a pandemic.
No one wants to change
into running shoes
right next to one of those
weirdly jacked 80-year-olds
air-drying his [bleep].
"Bad things happen
when I put it away wet."
Stay out of my space, grandpa.
Now's not the time to take
our foot off the gas --
if we just hunker down and spend
the next month or two
crushin' this thing, combined
with the ramped-up vaccinations,
we can have potentially
a great summer.
Think about it.
We could have block parties,
neighborhood barbecues,
street fairs.
Do you remember street fairs
in New York?
You'd be in a cab in a rush
heading to your apartment
and all of a sudden
the road would be closed
and you'd say, "Ah!
[Bleep] street fairs!"
We can have that back soon.
And yet if you express any
caution or hesitation at all
about opening up too quickly
in the hopes that we'll be able
to crush this thing
by summer, Fox News,
the same people who spread lies
about everything from masks
to social distancing to
lockdowns
to the COVID death toll to
vaccines to scam miracle cures,
had the gall to accuse you
of being pro-pandemic.
-We might be out of the pandemic
by summer, medically.
We'll see how long it will
take us to get out
of the pandemic politically.
Dr. Siegel, thanks so much for
telling us about this new point.
-Great point, Will.
There's plenty of people
that want that pandemic
to continue,
but it is not us.
Thanks for having me.
-Exactly.
-Are you out of your [bleep]
mind? Nobody wants
this godforsaken pandemic
to go on any longer.
We've all been trapped inside
for a year.
Forget going to gyms
or movie theaters,
I'd give anything to be
on a packed "F" train right now
without air conditioning,
getting crushed on one side
by a guy with a bike
and the other side by a guy
with a lizard on his shoulders.
This is the central story
of our politics right now.
One political coalition,
for all its faults,
is focused on
actually governing,
and the other has become
unmoored from reality
and fueled entirely by imagined
cultural grievances over
everything from children's books
to "The Muppets."
And with a few exceptions,
Republicans have made
the conscious decision
to lean into that.
They've made
the cynical calculation
that sticking with a racist,
authoritarian criminal
who sowed an insurrection
to overthrow democracy
is the path to power.
Senator Lindsey Graham
told Axios last night
he's trying to harness the
energy of the Trump movement.
-There's something about Trump.
There's a dark side
and there's some magic there.
And what I'm trying to do
is just harness the magic.
To me, Donald Trump is sort of
a cross between Jesse Helms,
Ronald Reagan, and P.T. Barnum.
-And that sounds like
a good combination to you?
Who else were you
going to include?
John Gotti and
Jabba the Hutt?
Also, what do you mean,
you want to "harness the magic?"
You sound like
a regional theater director
trying to whip your cast
into shape
for a production of "Our Town."
[ Southern accent ]
"Come on, people. You were
supposed to practice
these dance numbers
on your own time.
You need to stop whining
and harness the magic,
or else my Mee-maw's
is going to keep telling me
I wasn't cut out for Broadway.
At least I have dreams,
Mee-maw!"
The majority of
House Republicans
voted to overturn
the November election results,
and not a single one of them
voted to fund vaccinations
and send urgently-needed relief
to the American people
amid a pandemic
and economic crash.
That simple fact should tell
you everything you need to know
about the state of our politics.
Whatever their flaws, the
Democrats' message
to voters is this.
"Do you like checks?
Do you like
unemployment benefits?
Do you like money for children,
schools,
vaccines, and pensioners?"
And the Republicans' message
to voters is,
-"Do you like green eggs and
ham?"
-This has been a closer look.
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings
over two million meals a year to
men, women and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, wear a mask,
get vaccinated. We love you.